bring in
tom holman he's a fox news contributor
and retired acting ice director tom good
morning to you good morning
good morning you know the reason we
brought you in at the top of the hour
was uh there are three
people under arrest in
the san antonio area because yesterday
we got the news late in the day 46
migrants found inside
a tractor trailer
just outside of san antonio on a
deserted remote road there was no water
it was 103 degrees on the outside it was
a refrigerated tractor truck but the
refrigeration was not working and tom as
you look at these images they are just
heartbreaking but this you know the
governor of texas greg abbott said these
deaths are on joe biden they are a
result of his deadly open border
policies
well absolutely and last night brought
back a lot of bad memories for me that's
worst day in my life i actually stood in
the back
in the back of the tractor trailer at a
crime scene
with 19 dead migrants at my feet
including a five-year-old little boy
that's suffocated to death
these cases are similar both locked in a
steel box no water no they weren't using
the air conditioner that worked
um and people died horrific death
and i want to see it angers me because i
want to see the secretary homeland
security come out to press today come
out give a statement and continue to lie
to the american people that this border
secure and it's closed that you have
operational control of the border that
your policies are safe or inhumane
because the fact is your policies have
called record illegal has caused record
illegal immigration the more people that
cross that border the more that die
so under this administration they broke
a lot of records a record number of
migrants have already died on a job
buying over 700 now add 46 more to it a
record number of americans that die from
drug overdoses come across an open
border
it's it's just this this this
administration is breaking a lot of
records the records are all bad
historical illegal immigration by the
end of this fiscal year we're gonna have
close to four million encounters add to
that in other men got away that's five
million this administration is their
policy is inhumane and that's why to
this day i support president trump when
he was president who had the most secure
border in my lifetime a 40-year low
illegal immigration down 83 percent when
you secure the board that level you save
lives
save lives so i'm sick and tired of this
administration tell me how humane their
policies are and how secure the borders
it angers me especially this case i've
been there it changed me forever this is
horrific these people died horrific
tragic death
tom you were the acting ice director
under president trump well the man at
gonzales who has been tapped to lead ice
under joe biden has actually withdrawn
his name from consideration and he says
i am grateful to president biden for the
honor of nominating me and i wish this
administration well as it strives to
overcome the paralyzing political
gridlock that threatens far more than
our nation's border frankly the
dysfunction
threatens america's heart and soul what
is your response to that why do you
think he withdrew his name is he saying
that the administration is dysfunctional
he couldn't pass vetting he has a lot of
things in his background that it
prevented him past inviting right but
the bottom line is best thing that could
have happened to the ice agents that he
withdrew this administration searched
far far far and wide on who who who did
not cooperate with ice who talked bad
about ice who didn't believe in
immigration enforcement well they found
gonzales the same thing happened to cbp
let's find the chief of police that
refused to work with the border patrol
actually talked bad about the board of
trump policies and they found the the
cbp director magnus as the chief of
tucson this administration picked two
leaders of cbp and ice that they knew
despise the very organization they're
going to lead and why because they
wanted yet magnus not doing a thing to
secure the border that's exactly what
they want and and gonzalez was going to
get in the ice structures job and not
not allow ice to do their job so this is
the best thing that happened to ice that
he got out
so uh over the weekend they found 109
pounds of meth 18 pounds of fentanyl uh
1 260 migrants in seven large groups ten
sex offenders one active warrant one
gang member one agent assault so they
find these two california sheriffs find
these two guys with enough pills to kill
millions of americans and these guys who
were caught
are out on are out on supervised release
which is nothing i mean can you believe
these series of events that we're
reporting on you just list them and
you're horrified
i'm disgusted i'm disgusted because it's
i i don't look anybody's watching this
program now i don't care what your
opinion on is on illegal migration
because but when you have record illegal
immigration that takes up the 70 percent
of board replacements off the line 70
percent are off the line that's when
enough fentanyl comes across to kill
over 100 000 americans that that's when
like i said earlier over 700 migrant
deaths i don't care what your position
is illegal immigration but you should be
you should be disgusted as well as i am
that this administration is allowing
what's happening the the consequences of
open borders are is drugs from across
the country and no one suspected
terrorists crossed the country they've
arrested 50 they got over 800 000 got
aways how many of those 800 000 got
aways our national security threat that
came in this country do us harm if you
if no one's going to communicate 800 000
got aways from 161 countries many of
those countries sponsored terrorism you
can't convince me that not a single one
or eight hundred thousand came across
and got away and are now planning an
attack against this country
again i don't care what your what your
opinion is on illegal immigration this
is a national security issue this is a
public safety issue because of drugs and
it's certainly a public health issue
because your overdoses in the covenant
coming across the border people got to
stand up and demand accountability from
this president and the secretary who
needs to be impeached day one if we take
back congress he has failed american
people he's a secretary of homeland
insecurity we're less safe on his
leadership he has failed every month
well tom you know these guys were able
to they figured they could sneak the
fentanyl into the country because
all of our agents are busy processing
the millions of people who are coming
across because joe biden said don't come
but really he's letting them just come
on in as quickly as they can
at the very beginning when we described
the scene down in the san antonio
antonio area where the 46 migrants died
from the heat being trapped in that box
you said you had been inside
a box truck just like that when you were
serving
take us inside explain explain what goes
on is it just is it just an empty truck
my situation when i got the crime scene
i got back to tractor trailer
and there's 19 dead people at my feet
including a five-year-old little boy
everybody was in their underwear
trying to escape the massive heat it's
over 150 degrees in back of the truck it
was black
it was a steel chamber of death they
couldn't breathe there's no water
there's an air conditioning unit a
refrigeration unit that the truck driver
refused to use because he didn't want to
draw attention from the board trip
because he's supposed to be carrying
nothing
when you stay in the back of that
tractor trailer
and i've had a long career but that was
the worst day of my life and it changed
me forever because when i looked and i
thought about the last 30 minutes or
last hour of their life and i thought
about the little boy crying for his dad
to help him
who couldn't help him
that changed me forever and that's why
people say why do you get it so
emotional on tv why do you get emotional
about congress because through my career
steve i the one thing i've learned is
secure borders save lives when you have
a secure border and less people cross
less people die less vulnerable people
putting themselves in hand of criminal
organizations who don't give a damn
about these people they're just a way to
make money and that's why we keep going
back when i talk about securing the
board president trump is greatest
president in my lifetime when it comes
to the border security because he saved
blinds by securing the border and this
administration came in and purposely
unsecured it and now we see the results
thousands of americans are dying
you know we got over 700 migrant deaths
now another 46. it's disgusting
but that's why that's why
it was a nightmare
that's why may orcas you can impeach him
but the next person is going to be just
as bad because it all comes from
president biden he does not care and if
he cared me orchestra who knows what
kind of job he would do but it doesn't
matter you could have that job tom they
wouldn't let you do it you'd have to
quit
i understand that they look this this is
all in joe biden he ran and opens
borders he signed over 90 executive
orders basically abolishing every policy
of the trump administration the american
people need to stand up nuts and raise
hell because people are dying we got to
stop the madness i don't even know why
they get in the back of these trucks
because i see so many videos of
lines of people just walking through the
rio grande walking across into america
yeah they don't even need a truck
tom it's uh just heart because because
these people because these people don't
want to be arrested they're paying the
criminal cartels like but they know they
may get arrested they might find a title
42 they want to get away so the
smuggling organization they can take a
pickup truck to smuggle 12 or they could
tractor trailer smuggle 80 they'll make
a hell of a lot more money and again
they don't care they put these people on
a steel box in order conditioning it's
all about the money these criminal
organizations they're animals they're
vicious
thank you so much for coming on with us
tom